( laughing )
I like you, Amy.
I like you, too.
Yeah.
In fact, I thought
maybe we could...
have a sleepover tonight.
A sleepover?
Yeah, a sleepover.
Is that something that
you would be into?
Yeah, I would
totally be into that.
Yeah?
I did want to tell
you something,
before we go any further,
and it may be like
a total dealbreaker
and I won't judge
you either way, I promise.
I'm sure it's fine.
What is it?
I...
have AIDS.
What's up?
Did you hear
what I just said?
Oh, did you say something?
Did you hear what I said and
you're pretending you didn't
so you don't have to actually,
like, talk about--
Yeah, I do.
Okay...
Is that a dealbreaker
for you, or...
No, no, no, no, no.
No! No, no!
That's true.
No, that's not
a deal breaker.
Oh my God, AIDS?
That?
No, that's great.
No, it's not great.
I'm not saying, like,
that's great.
I just, like--
Actually, you know what?
It makes me more confident
in our relationship.
You know?
'Cause I just--
Like, I really, I really
like you, I don't know.
I don't know
what I'm saying, ahh.
Like what kind of AIDS?
HIV?
Uh, no--
Full-blown--
Full-blown AIDS.
Oh, like the virus
that causes AIDS?
No, it already caused it.
For what?
For being honest
about your... AIDS,
and the state it's in.
I don't know
what I'm saying.
I want you to know that it
doesn't bother me at all.
It doesn't bother me
at all that you have it,
and my dad has psoriasis,
so I get it.
Amy, are you okay with this?
It's-- it's really fine
if you're not.
Um...
Actually, I think
I am okay with it.
I think I really am.
Sorry, I kinda--
Had a moment there.
I mean, people do this.
If we just use protection
and, you know, don't, like,
share needles,
then we should be fine.
You are so high-
maintenance, my God.
Garcon, the lady will have
her own needle.
Shut up.
Are-- are we okay?
Yeah, yeah.
We are, we're okay.
God, I think it's kind of
cool, it's kind of badass.
Like, the '90s are back.
Okay.
Yeah.
Do you go to, like,
a lot of events?
No, I go to
a lot of doctors.
Yeah, well.
Cheers.
What?
Mmm, this is really good.
This wine will actually
go amazing with this
cayenne chocolate
torte that they have.
That does sound amazing,
I can't have that.
I have a gluten allergy.
So that torte would be,
like, my AIDS.
Oh, are you going
to the bathroom?
Is this AIDS-related?
Full disclosure, I didn't
see "Philadelphia,"
but I did see "Gia,"
and, like, the tail end
of "Precious,"
so I feel
prepared to help.
No, I'm leaving.
I'm sorry, I'm a total foodie
and I think that
gluten allergies
are just bull( bleep ).
Later, Amy.
I-- I think you're forgetting
who has AIDS here.
You have AIDS here.
What?